Oh
[Music]
this one goes out to all of y'all who's
struggling to get high views on YouTube
I'm about to tell you the secret that no
one knows about to accept me and cuz I
just figured it out
listen carefully boys and girls hey yo
it's the number one [ __ ] lever back
the seat down relax
here have a snack have a moan do
six-pack I'm sorry for my grammar swag
but we're getting up to track the song
it's about Iraq no I'm not talking about
the nation I'm here to tell you all
about the Great Tribulation if you
refresh your videos for more YouTube
views that you might be seduced they
might come to use we all been there we
all have struggled you try to get four
subs
they just another scrubs here's how to
do collabs but they just give you some
crabs you're trying to false flag and
your massive false flags with the sacred
to YouTube use there must be a trick are
they part of Illuminati no its way that
came in do they work really hard do they
come here no you got it all wrong good
shake relaxing at it
get some money I'm really [ __ ] wack
[ __ ] no I can't do that that's not very
nice for a mountain
think about it twice person it
[ __ ] with the boobs
okay I'm sorry sorry the trick is
simpler I learned from the best
the secret lies within an icy pony plays
chess you may want to consider having
implants that are having em okay how
don't get me wrong I'm not being sexist
as long as you that poop they don't
matter what your sex is yours a picture
on your deck ain't nobody's gonna click
on that [ __ ] come on man arrow Destro's
you should consider having implants you
should consider having implants
everybody you should consider having
implants you should consider having
implants
another term is to commit are you gonna
be a [ __ ] or you gonna make people
click on that jig legit just think of
all the reasons I know you wanna just
panic and Matt it and make us try yours
get busy wedding
[Music]
[ __ ] it's a
but what about name
kidding as long as I can put a bungee
booby
with the boobs and
[ __ ] you should assume now
the truth should the city hand
everybody
get the music is singing
but but I'm a boy
well under code ownership
[Music]
but the truth is sitting having implants
boobs boobs
[Music]
hope you bros enjoy this song you can
get it right now on iTunes if it beats
any top list then I'll reveal who's the
true identity of Falcon lover in the
next video